so I'm going through and I mean this was
everywhere yesterday the real winners
here are the bagel boss in Long Island
yeah they are the store is called the
bagel bus to the original boy that's a
few more than I thought okay the
original has 18 point 1 million views
and that's not even taking into account
all of the ripoffs of it you know cuz so
many people I'm sure just download it
off the original Twitter account that it
came out on and post it on their own
Twitter account so you're definitely
looking I would guess over the course of
24 hours somewhere in the 22 to 25
million range of views yeah a little
shirt little shirt yeah it's so small
it's not supposed to be that long but a
diminutive shirt his torso is so short
it's not supposed to fall that low on
the waist but his torso is shorter than
you know the average male that it's
designed for his shorts that the man's
wearing see how far below the knee they
go they're not supposed to go that low
but you know what happened his legs are
little too I bet he had been striking
out on dating site and I think the woman
had played probably quarters biting her
liver smirking over him like he's a
child the quarter making some kind of
look and just exploded he threw a temper
tantrum they went to the this bagel
store bagel boss in Long Island who by
the way have celebrated so much I think
they posted a tweet or something that
said anybody that comes in and mentions
this video gets a free mini bagel which
is gonna cost him a lot of mini bagels
bagel boss it's delicious it is but is
it a chain yeah it's a chain I see yeah
I see well they're having a great day
this is this guy they are having a great
day this guy he's you know he's clearly
a Long Island guy he sounds like he's a
Long Island guy yeah he actually he's a
loyal and he acts like he's a Long
Island guy he how tall would you say he
is five feet he said something but he
says his height 5 foot he's in he says
something about 5 feet they say things
like you should be dead like these this
guy's probably been tortured on dating
sites let me tell you something he gives
it away early what's got to him and you
kind of feel bad for him I don't I felt
I felt bad for his life like he's being
a dick but I was like oh but you know
what
doesn't just get made fun of for being
short it's not like this is the first
time he's gotten over angry he's a
[ __ ] he might be a dick this is
better this is network this is I'm as
mad as hell yeah this is what it looks
like in real life this is the
culmination this is what it looks like
when it's not scripted by Paddy
Chayefsky yeah this is how but this is
the culmination of all this he's been a
[ __ ] the whole time however I will
tell you this is exactly why when I was
a kid and I was short and the doctor
said you probably won't get past five
one I was like twelve right I started
doing HGH because I realized the life of
a shrimp adult male yeah is nothing I
want to experience I said if I get made
fun of in school for being short imagine
being an adult you go into even if
you're like a super powerful guy you go
into a business meaning you got a suit
on you could be the boss the minute you
leave everybody's making fun even for
being a little guy
it's like Pacino or or Tom Cruise who
are not tall guys but it's amazing how
people will sit like no one knows that
but when people say I met I like yeah
sure I thought immediately no one is
ever happily shorter no one's about toes
so go my god she was shorter than I
thought well it's okay for girls to be
shorter yeah it's true but because that
can be cute some people like it's not
the worst thing in the world or he's
sure yeah just the idea being shorter
than expected is never a good thing
right
even if you don't you have the you hear
that conversation when they're talking
about actors oh did you know like that's
the third trivia that comes up every
time within the top three trivia remarks
it's he's actually really short and they
doesn't think they've done part like
like things on how many presidents have
one that were taller yeah of course
almost all of them of course we're
taller there is something visually we're
Apes we just look at the taller person
and that's the person we kind of defer
to that's the authority figure
I trust that person yeah we go back to
being kids when we look at adults as
being big yeah so once we become adults
and somebody who's smaller than us is
telling us what to do we go how would
you know you know what are you doing how
would you what are you playing like what
do you play pretend and then there's
guys like El Chapo which I think even
means shorty yeah who's were where the
the lack of height is their power like
he's
the fact that effective runs a cartel
that helps but you're such a [ __ ]
sometimes those little guys who run
powerful organizations are very feared
too because there's nothing scarier than
an angry little guy sometimes that's
what motivates them to be such fierce
leaders right an angry little fella you
don't want you don't want to mess with
an angry little well sometimes it's okay
to mess with angry little fellas budgets
that bagel guy yeah I had the ability to
have your head cut off dude the whole
store with that little guy had El Chapo
power that entire bagel store would be
on fire dude he would have burned them
he had his guys shoot them yeah the
store would've been blown take seven
women who laughed at him he had done her
last oh yeah you see what you did yeah
he would have made her watch and then he
would have started cutting off her
fingers let me watch this whenever so
lately he doesn't have that kind of
power certainly does not does not catch
it where he says five feet high oh yeah
he says his height and that they laugh
at him on dating sites I know exactly
what you're talking about so this this
little fella he looks like he's probably
in his late 40s early fifties maybe 50
yeah yeah 45 40 somewhere between 45 and
50 one and he's ordering bagels and he's
obviously in some kind of a mood because
he said something the girl I get the
coat the girls Berkey on him over him he
could quarter smirking he said the lip
by it like he caught somebody giving a
look and he just has had it and he
looked at this girl and he blamed her
for every girl that's ever looked at him
like a goofball bloated and then he and
then it just didn't get any better
great why is it okay for women to say oh
you're five feet our dating site you
should be dead that's okay by the way
you're never sorry I don't wanna keep
interrupting no we can enter when you
throw down your newspaper and you put
your arms out like that's never you you
know one six foot one does that now stop
throwing your paper down damn that's
like a little rascals move especially
because when he pushes his fist towards
the ground he looks like he's about to
start the Lollipop Guild dance that's
representing
that's exactly what he looks like don't
do it don't do that damn it hmm yeah
because it highlights the fact that your
limbs are shorter than the average limb
that was really throwing the paper
downwards the bed that was a 1940s movie
movie that's also this is the moment
that you know we've already gone too far
when he's sitting there and he's blaming
the girl in the bagel shop for the women
on dating apps not giving him the time
of day they're not related they had it
back and forth obviously he probably
said something about her appearance and
she says who knows I don't know how I
can't even speculate but I know that she
should be dead the girl who filmed this
said that she looked up smiled at him
and asked what he wanted and he took
that as a smirk and like you're making
fun of my height weight the girl behind
the counter then no no yes the girl
behind the counter smirked at him and so
he started saying something to girl
behind the counter and that's when the
girl who's filming says yeah why do you
degrade women and then he goes it's okay
but ever say I should be dead and by the
way that's never happened on dating
sites I don't think anybody said you're
only five feet tall why don't you just
die exactly that's um what happened
someone said kill yourself or you should
be someone who said that totally because
of his temper maybe yeah
or he said something like what do you
think I should just kill myself and
somebody said yeah just don't go for
women in general had settled on dating
sites you think I'm making that [ __ ] up
everywhere I go I get the same [ __ ]
smart with the biting lip that's where
you know it's real
with the biting lip it's a biting lip
he's getting he's tired of getting
laughed at and be Leia I don't hate this
dude man like I get he's being a dick
but he's just exploding the smirk he
probably thinks she's cute but he also
gets it he doesn't just get laughed at
for being short he probably acts like a
tough guy he might and when he walk over
paranoid yeah when you walk around
acting like a tough guy it's true and
you're sure you're this guy like it's
funny watching a couple situps
yeah okay I'm gonna say like he's not in
the best shape
sometimes when you're taller and you you
know ingest all the calories there's
more room for them to spread out and
unfortunately he eats like he's six foot
know he's five he's a diminutive man he
doesn't have socks on and it does
collect in the belly but he was having a
healthy breakfast
Travis you were able to document what
the breakfast was yeah what was it the
whole wheat bagel with one egg white and
Swiss cheese he's trying to lose the way
his bagel is trying to you know why he's
trying to lose the weight the girls
probably make fun of his gun too that's
right
you know they probably they probably
make a little bit fun of him but you
know what I also think I don't think
that the meals stopped at breakfast in
the morning I think there's an
in-between meal snack between breakfast
my nose first breakfast I think there
might be a second because they yeah it
was in one of the articles do you know
oh yeah this this case by the way has
been very well documented when you [ __ ]
with someone who's short like there's a
story for many years ago my friend Dean
who is now dead was of 17 he was in a
roller rink and it was a dwarf and the
roller rink so my friend Dean did the
thing where he was behind the guy and he
did his own like he put his hand like he
was saluting to set his own height and
then in his stomach to make fun of the
height of the other guy and the guy saw
him do it
so the guy turned around on skates
uh-huh and skate that to my friend and
threw up against the banister he was
being in the bathroom and I he's like
what no I didn't do a bathroom and my
friends like no awesome yeah yeah yeah I
think that this guy you don't get made
fun of to that degree just for walking
around being short why not this guy and
you also don't go from oh I'm just a
mild-mannered happy-go-lucky easy to get
along with dude - now I'm gonna threaten
everybody in this bagel store his
day-to-day is not the most pleasant even
though he knows his threats won't even
taken seriously
they shouldn't be I know and he knows
that but don't make those threats then
tell me what are you doing is nothing
worse is a man though when you're angry
and someone what he's probably better
that position you think with women
before yeah
no okay listen to me and their gig okay
what do you what do you want what should
what should I listen to yeah we do see
though rewind a little bit we do see as
he starts to so this is when the the
guys start to get involved relax relax
he sees the levels of authority as God
and then his dad and then his bombs
right that sounds right
yeah that sounds about right repeat
three entities who are disappointed in
him yeah and II seen his boss kind of
laugh like it was a short guy thinks
he's gonna be in charge here somebody
wants to be the boss yeah forklift
operator he needs a little boost yeah
well guy I mean I don't you can't if you
walk around acting like a tough guy and
you're not a tough guy and people laugh
at you because you act like a tough guy
even though you're not that's not the
people's fault if you're not a tough guy
right don't don't act like a tough guy
right I mean that's you can't not
everybody gets to be a tough guy believe
it or not physically I'm not the
toughest guy I find that hard to believe
I believe the power of repulsing people
that's true so I avoid situations right
now hug them in they're like all right
whatever you want when you run your
mouth so much yes like I don't want
nothing to do with this guy and then
occasionally you get called out and then
you get humiliated when you do get
called out cuz most people don't want to
get in a fight right they don't but
sometimes people are like I'm I have an
issue with the other guy - yeah
tremendous issue
yeah no that's fair all right let's keep
it moving that's one of my favorite
parts hit pause I might scare to you
when he chest bumps him except he had
some in the waist with just steps up to
him any chest bumps him he pushes the
little guy pushes his chest right in
this big guy's face and it's hilarious
for a couple reasons number one Lee's
little tippy toes he's on his tip tippy
toes he's on his tiptoes but his his
chest makes contact with the guy's waist
even on his tiptoes yeah you know why by
the way this guy the the the short guys
I mean he's a little full of it too cuz
he knows that that guy's not gonna fight
him there that's the other thing he
knows he won't probably get his ass
kicked when you're little you know that
most people aren't gonna beat up the
little guy so you can run your mouth
yeah um the other thing is that with the
girl that's framing this video because
she's trying to get the short guy in the
shot the short guy is so short that you
get his entire head-to-toe body in the
video but the guy that he's threatening
you can't see you can only see this you
don't even see his head it looks like
the nanny and Muppet baby or Jack and
the Beanstalk giant man yeah you never
see the actual face or shoulders or
anything like that it's like I'm sorry
no it's good if somebody knows how to
choke somebody out mm-hmm like this
where a guy's just running his mouth and
being an [ __ ] and chest bumping
mm-hmm when you choke somebody out
you're not really hurting them you're
just stopping subduing yeah I like when
when he's telling the guy to shut up
mm-hmm he says you're not you're not God
or my father or or my boss or my boss he
stops his thought and then he decides to
tack another one out in case the boss
you know is listening right my boss
because you know actually he is a thorny
finger too
yeah let's be factual here if my boss
told me to stop I guess I
woody is the boss after all ya know just
for living what I don't know I want to
know that I do want to know about this
guy but I want to see him get in trouble
I'm just dying to know what his life is
like he's this is another guy that like
he doesn't need to get in any trouble
whatsoever he's become an international
star he has it and he shouldn't he
shouldn't people know him the world over
today he's the bagel guy yeah he can't
what can you imagine the little angry
man walking around his neighborhood he's
got a little hat on now first of all he
can't get his morning bagel and for
goddamn sure everyone knows who he is in
the neighborhood he's gonna have to get
Ober eats because you see this guy in a
bagel store you know honestly he should
set up a little business for himself and
just do meet and greets and bagel stores
would you would you want to get a photo
with him in a bagel store this week yeah
I really that's a great idea right I
wonder if he goes back in if he went
back and apologized where they still
serve Him if he went back in and goes
look I was completely crazy I'm sorry
you never know what the business would
do because it's been so good for the
business they might serve Him and then
he'd flip out again eventually this
isn't this is eventually probably within
the week this isn't a guy who's only
done this once I hope he doesn't do it
again to try to get another viral video
I'd be great he's just a flip-out guy
like the way like network but he's bad
the next time when they're trying to get
Howard Beale to flip out every week
because I was good for ratings he should
put out a t-shirt and it's got he's
gonna have his face on it and the top
says you're not God and then his face
and then or my father and then on the
back you know so my boss yeah that's
great
they're not gonna go back to bagel boss
though no what about a differing they're
giving out free mini bagels they mention
this video being a oh my god I don't
connect the mini to his height yeah yeah
because he's a little guy they don't
make mini bagels they're making him
especially for this guy they saw how
easy that's like if he's black I think
you've had only pumpernickel yeah oh
[ __ ] they saw me make that connection
they saw how much it bothered him and so
they decided to rub his face in it they
loved the publicity publicity bit just a
felicity that they're getting tough word
great I didn't care say yep
they don't make many bagels no they just
make regular bagels
people are definitely on his bagel boss
today hoping that they get a just
because they wanna get a look oh I
wonder if that was my cuz they probably
look similar if it's a chain I wonder if
that was my bagel boss oh I should go to
bagel boss today who knows what's gonna
happen we'll definitely have his name by
Monday I'm surprised we don't already
it's probably out there somewhere no I'm
I really think I've checked every
Twitter everything I can't it'll come
out today I just curious what he does
like like yeah where does he work that
his boss tells him what to do under his
father and God oh my boss or my boss
okay now we know you're gainfully
employed okay let's go back to it that's
the other t-shirt
I just wanted bagels a picture of the
guy so what happened was the guy goes
hey shut up and then he goes you shut
the [ __ ] up what did you just come on
and attack me and this giant guy or
maybe he's average height and he just
looks Jolyon next to this little fella
he rushes him pushes him down to the
ground subdues him and it looks like in
the last frame of the video i think he
pulls his t-shirt over his head by the
way this is what I don't like about that
guy who tackled him mm-hmm
I know that this guy's asking for it
he's being a complete dick he literally
says attack me but if that's the [ __ ]
guy from the Disney fight is that
[ __ ] tough guy running over and
grabbing him pink shirt guy or white
shirt guy the guy who tackled him pink
shirt no no I'm saying design the blue
Disney fight video oh you're saying that
if pink shirt guy is a short guy he's
right floating in that bagel store
people would tell them hey calm down and
relax man but would this guy run over
and he's also assessing the situation I
mean yes he knows that he that he can
stop this problem he probably knows that
he can't stop pink shirt no but that's
this fair it is but yeah it's also it's
self-preservation he's also not like
booting him up no he's no I know that
but he tell you them to tackle him the
guy wasn't physically threatening
anybody just being a dick nobody was
really going after everybody yeah I
guess and sometimes you just have to
stop I just don't like it's again I've
said this many times but it's why I
don't scream at old people in the street
because I wouldn't scream at the guy
from Disney so I'm not gonna be a
[ __ ] tough
with a little old lady and then be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] when I are you comparing
this little bagel guy to a little old
lady he wouldn't like that if you heard
that you pyrite we love comparing to the
guy Disney and a little old lady or some
of the characters yeah maybe
Chippendale what okay
maybe the mice from Cinderella yeah
Jiminy Cricket I love Disney characters
these are the small ones
I don't pull oppa yeah it's not Disney
but it works that's true I was just
saying it's topical it works if you
chest bump somebody like that is that
assault you know what that is true he
did chest pump a Gaiden I mean to saucam
it's cute no judge would give you it
long you could you contact see the kid
throws a rattle is it assault it's a
crime fight if the cops came you could
have them
cuff him for assault but there's no way
he would get assault charges but yes you
can you could claim assault so you could
I guess sure you're right he did chest
you know what he did physically contact
somebody anyways saying you know meet me
outside you want to attack like show it
goes back to this thing of you're right
big guys shouldn't attack small guys but
at the same time small guys shouldn't
drastic fights with big also very true
yura and this guy did but the bottom
line is he didn't grab this guy but this
guy might have been afraid to hit a lady
or so all right you know what I'm mixed
on it yeah I don't like [ __ ] grabbing
a guy when you wouldn't grab a big guy
but then again just because you wouldn't
grab a big guy doesn't mean that you
shouldn't grab a little guy who's
[ __ ] everybody either right right and
he is just subdue him I totally get your
point the principal the bigger principle
of it now look with me because a lot of
people have not I haven't seen this
pointed out but to me it does appear
that the little man's shirt is pulled
over his head let me see that okay wow I
just live by the way that that guy
doesn't even take a second from saying
attack me too actually
he puts him on yeah he goes come and
attack me guy goes you got it that guy
did that guy he's a genie
your wish is my man he was attacking out
of anger though like he tackled this
little [ __ ] it's like come on
man you have to do and he didn't hit him
yeah he didn't hit him he wanted to
charge him and attack him
yeah he wanted to get him down on the
ground and stop what was going on so did
everybody in this yeah I understand I
understand you see the very last scene
it looks like the shirts over his head
when the very last frame my mistake
maybe Oh which parts you I never saw the
other one even if it's not as good is it
after this happens yes
part two is definitely worth watching so
he's still yelling after this yes and
that's right part two
that's why I tell you haven't seen it
the Godfather - that's why I mean I
don't know if it's as good as Godfather
- that's pretty good compared to one but
dad isn't three that's why I tell you
that this guy this is not he didn't just
get caught on a bad day
this is habitual why is that I does not
get made fun of for being short he gets
made fun of for being short and acting
like he's a tough guy everywhere why why
the [ __ ] did that woman stop filming she
just wanted bagels I mean she stopped
for a man as a camera person who gave us
this I'm greedy I'm sorry you really are
I mean she got it you're right I'm sure
you're right beautiful moment but
there's on all of us to enjoy all right
let's see what happens I think he gets
scared cuz you're just not used to
somebody how do you mean when you and
your video source
yeah that's sitting there thinking about
creating Kanye yeah thinking about the
fact that just 30 seconds ago the videos
like 30 seconds long 30 seconds ago you
were just peacefully ordering bagels
right she says it I just wanted bagels
then over the course of 30 seconds some
shrimp of a man starts yelling at
everybody threatening to beat everybody
up chest bumping somebody's waist and
then a big six-foot guy comes and
tackles him and pulls his shirt up over
his head what did you just walk into hey
let's go to Ryan in Long Island cuz I
believe him
let's go to run now sets wait what's
that Brian no the phones weren't turned
on why I don't know what's up Brian Ryan
yes Hey first of all Travis they
absolutely make mini bagels dummy
yes stupid
so soon hey stupid idiot maybe maybe
they should make [ __ ] bagels for
Travis tomorrow because he's so stupid
exactly about [ __ ] one big bagel one
small bagel and then the big bagel
leaves in a small bagel Christ
okay that's so personal reference to his
mother leaving yep saying they should
make his bagel mom will you go on Ryan
but yeah I don't know how true it is but
I definitely see like screenshots of
tinder and [ __ ] like that
where girls will be very means of people
who are under six feet understand how
real or white yes it is like that it's
like if you're under six feet you should
kill yourself like I'll see things like
that I've never used a dating site but I
don't know how real or widespread it is
but it's like a meme on the internet for
sure what is that is that a goofy quote
in their profile or are they messaging
people saying hey you you are short you
should kill yourself yeah that's
definitely in their profile but I don't
know if people are that mean I've never
I've never used ender I didn't with my
girlfriend you know what it is dude he's
right I'll bet you there's a lot of
women who's going alongside Ryan yeah
you get old sometimes yeah I bet you a
lot of girls he's liked have said hey
you know a certain height or whatever or
he's talked to them a little bit and
they've realized he was short and they
stopped talking to him or he just is
like he's probably talked to girls who
say they have a height requirement and
then he's like yeah but I'll show her
I'm better I'm different and then
they're not attracted to you yeah I
believe what Ryan saying I can buy that
there are women on like tinder and
whatnot that have in their profiles
memes about you know anybody under six
feet should die or whatever thinking
it's a joke but I don't believe that
there's been a plethora of women that
have messaged this guy personal right
and said hey since you're five feet tall
you should kill yourself you know I
think he's just read it on profiles of
women that he was attracted to that he
didn't have a shot with anyway it's
right and he took a person
either way either way he shouldn't be a
dick but I do feel for the guy I do too
he's a short guy I mean he also uses
that as an excuse when like the real
issue is that he's just an [ __ ] yeah
he's not an attractive person nobody
would want to hang out with him I would
I talked to him for a while
get him all revved up again what he's
love to interview him oh my god I want
nobody on the radio more than him
I would love it I'd sit there every
podcast with him I'd sit there and like
you butter him up like oh man you look
great today Bob why do you think they
were doing mini bagels yeah it's just
because it would take this really
degrading it would take two seconds for
either one and we could get him up and
down like a roller coaster the whole
time it'd be a blast
let me see part twos I didn't even know
this existed I'm so happy wait a minute
we have our own isn't rob a little
shrimp of a guy how tall is Rob I mean
yes cute that's what I'm saying shape
he's handsome with clothes on yeah yeah
but Rob doesn't have to do yeah this
guy's gonna do it Rob does work to get
not have a gut Rob goes to the gym no no
I'm saying here's have to deal with what
this guy lives with the better-looking
dude he's got his hair this guy wants to
make it seem like because he's short
this is all happening to him part of it
yeah when in reality Rob is a little
tiny guy but it helps that he's
good-looking and he has a personality
but he's not an [ __ ] that's the thing
just being short is this guy's not this
guy's biggest problem exactly he's an
[ __ ] that's the biggest problem
yeah but women are supposed to like
[ __ ] not when you're threatening to
beat them up in a bagel store I know
you're fat and you're like yeah you're
older guy and it's like Rob we're
talking about this guy I forgot you're
the expert on guys five six come on five
six not bad
no five six isn't bad I know because
he's five five he's not five six does he
can't be five seconds now five six I am
no you're five five do you think he's
five six try no he's not five six he's
ready five five-and-a-half totally five
nine I'm five I'm fine I say I'm five
ten because I'm five nine and a half
that's girl yeah five seven but guess
what five almost five seven I did growth
hormones when I was a kid otherwise I'd
be a tiny little guy yeah whatever they
work without big head there's no way
Rob's five six of fives not five six
he's now should we get a measuring tape
no no no we know we know maybe I don't
know you get a measuring tape and we
could measure the difference from a
[ __ ] a rafter to the floor and then
we if you hang yourself with it we can
measure the distance before subtract
he's gonna say maybe do a measurement
around the neck area yeah sure yeah yeah
for a collar of a shirt or so yeah yeah
yeah yeah but like have you had a short
person discrimination no yeah because
you know he's handsome he's a handsome
guy but he's also handsome Rob so that
like he's a he's a good-looking guy that
but he's also he's a cool dude pretty
short though
and he keeps himself in shape yeah yeah
yeah I mean good huh
dresses now he dresses well yeah this
guy could maybe maybe he shouldn't shop
in the boys section dude of the store
but dude also Rob towers over him yes
exactly he's Rob's right he's six inches
shorter than Rob not I feet is small
Rob's not five six alright five five
five inches he's five yeah Rob is five
inches taller he's my dick woods shorter
than Rob yeah no you're right I mean
being five five and being five-foot are
not to say do that foot is right under
it is a is [ __ ] or dwarf or whatever
little person I bet about Peter Dinklage
Fox huh Peter Dinklage is yeah but
English is handsome personality and he's
also a full tweeze a dwarf Peter did a
lot of cash to is a dwarf he can act
he's good-looking you're saying this
guy's a short talentless bum yeah well
this guy is five-foot so he's not he
doesn't fit in anywhere right he's not
technically a little person because he's
five foot he's probably 411 but still
he's doing some rob math there dude he's
right on the [ __ ] Kush
do you know what I mean probably is 411
because even girls are like right at
that 5-foot height yeah you know like
you I mean if a girl is five feet even
that's like that short cute height right
being five but he's like a little
shorter probably it's like probably 4 11
and 3/4 that little baby gut that's the
thing he doesn't keep himself in shape
that's a personal decision
dude he's being a 5-foot tall man sucks
yeah why do you think I did that 5 sucks
why you think I did injections every
other three year everyday everyday
injections for three years is that give
you like does that make tumors bigger
eventually too or no I certainly hope
not but I'll let you know when we get
there when you're older so like if you
have a little bit of cancer growing in
you and you start taking that it just
speeds it up but now but he's already
Sam's did it I mean yeah I don't know I
don't think then you had cancer in you
but no no hopefully not if if I did then
look at me I beat it with no medicine
that's not impressive
Thank You Man appreciate that yeah no I
and it's not like they were they were
putting growth hormone in my body
the average person would have had anyway
okay they were replenishing what you
should have although the one thing I do
I wish I had been working out well
oh my god that would have been great
everything would but I'd you know what
what are you gonna do that's right what
are you gonna do at least I'm not 5 feet
getting mad at people in a bagel store
show me part 2 papers so this is after
they've cleared everybody out
I guess they broke it up in this I love
somebody else video this is a different
person video now ok and and the guy is
trying to just wrap up his visit at the
bagel store
in trucks and it dropped his bagel oh he
did not cuz his fingers are so little he
went to grab it and walk out and he
dropped it because I've [ __ ] little
hands little stiff gargoyle hands
couldn't grab it his fingers are too
little and he's trying to play the
victim you know when you know you're
short when you can describe a man as
being three times the size of you yet
like that means that I mean with the
average height three times would be like
a giant and and the bottom line is that
guy a 'cold him who I thought the guy
was a dick for tackling it but then
again he said good tackle he was too
literally said please attack me I just
chest bump this man at the Ditka it's
not used to guys calling him out for
yeah that's why it's hateable because
he's threatening people and he's and
he's you know pushing them to actually
attack him and then afterwards he's like
Oh a guy attacks me three times
themselves that's okay it's like
somebody on Twitter who says something
and then you bashed him and they go to
Victor's followers right shut up you
started it you said something you
started it I thought you wanted the
smoke oh no so he dropped let me see him
drop his little [ __ ] wheel again and
he drops it and he doesn't want to pick
it up too embarrassing pick it up videos
not over right yak sighs he's acting
like he threw the bagel down he dropped
it said to [ __ ] your food I don't even
want it but he dropped her cuz his
fingers are short everything on him is
smaller than the average size yeah of
course watching force trying to pay that
first set cash all over the ground here
[Music]
Oh a party laughs no and why he didn't
want that he didn't want that he wants
to be scary and [ __ ] and you want to be
sympathetic and go like oh you didn't
have to laugh at him he's having a bad
day but at the same time when a guy is
in there going [ __ ] you [ __ ] all of you
you'd like really acting like a total
dick and he comes across looking like a
fool
you're within your right - laughing yeah
and there's a bunch of women who aren't
scared of him no and I believe that that
teenage girl over there in the glasses
is the one that was videoing him in the
first video I believe okay
she's zero she is the I just came here
to get some bagels oh I think that
that's the new Kevin Smith I'm not even
supposed to be here today from now on
people are gonna start saying I just
want some bagels hey pick this food up
and got it no I'm gonna take it now that
you laugh at me now we're gonna take the
food I paid for he wanted me to pay for
it you know would be brilliant when I
was I would just if this whole thing
they should just turn this around and go
part three have him yelling again and
then have somebody offer him a Snickers
you're not you when you're hungry it's
perfect he's angry he thought he
realizes he is because he just got
tackled to the ground
humiliated everybody saw it happening
he's still at a thousand and he realizes
if I don't get a bagel in my system
right now I'm gonna just be angry all
day I need to calm down oh no don't
don't zoom in on his feet again what's
wrong with his feet Jim please don't
tell me he's yelling on his tiptoes
again well it looks like his little
heels are lifted I'm gonna tell you
something his heels are not firmly
planted on the ground they're lifted
look at this woman she's probably five
five yeah look how I mean he is Jennifer
do you know why he's on his tiptoes
he can't see over the counter he's tired
of [ __ ] peeking in and always seen
the lower room
little bacon he'd even know they had a
top shelf there remember when you were a
little kid and you couldn't see over the
counter but imagine if you were an adult
yep like sometimes when I'm like I have
to like pick my daughter up so she can
see something yeah
you think people have to do that for him
yes they don't know anyone's and he
doesn't want them to but he does you
guys yeah I can't go to concerts uppy
oh yeah Abby if he's not in the front
row of concerts forget it he's got to be
in the upper tier balcony death row that
he does cuz you know why it why
everybody everybody so much taller than
his poor guy torturing movies oh no you
get a better few that way but they know
you know because both halves of him are
small so even when he's sitting down
even though everybody sitting his torso
is so small that he sinks into the chair
and he's perfect height for a coach seat
but too fat for a coach seat yeah he is
he could be really comfortable in that
Coach C sure but he let himself go a
little bit he really did and you know
what he looks like in the movie that
stick straight out who was it Lily
Tomlin that used to do that bit where
she was sitting in that giant chair on
stage that's him at the movies his legs
don't bend over the end he said Chelsea
she's leg bending over the end cuz his
knees are on the seat yep you know how
your knees hinge over the seat it's done
in no cuz if your back is against the
chair his ankles go over the little
blocks on the [ __ ] gas and brake
pedal you think he's got a specially
made car you bet he does unfortunate
that's really that's really tough xxx
this friends pile out of it except he's
not a little person so he doesn't have
that community right like little people
are like you're not one of us but
average-sized people are going look how
look how small you are cuz you you can't
make fun of little people but you can
make fun of short people yeah he's just
sure it's just short really really short
let me see the rest there's a lot more
of this video there is what he's mad he
picked up his braid no got it he first
received his breakfast but his little
fingers are too short so he dropped it
then he yelled at them because they
laughed at him then he went back to pick
up his breakfast and said you know what
I'm gonna take my breakfast I know stop
eating carbs fatty
[Music]
olia Yuri said all you women treat short
guys like [ __ ] yeah he's got he's got
really yeah he's got real anti-woman
issues
yeah he's another in cell mass murderer
yeah I mean that's yeah oh yeah anybody
that maybe they're not even hot no no no
a bunch of threes there's Long Island
bagel store employees they do yeah
they have vaginas and that species yeah
has been very rude to him in the past
and I bet you he's not looking at a
short woman either
like he's not trying for four eight four
nine or five he's trying to date women
who were [ __ ] 511 who just I get it I
was too but you don't want it because
he's a tough guy you forget he's a tough
guy
but even women that sighs don't want a
guy that short you know like a for a
woman wants a big six-foot guy yeah yeah
or at least you know five seven five
eight yeah you know a little bit bigger
cuz the girls like to wear heels so I
mean you can't wear heels around this
guys right right and and you know you
you women like to be in the president
they like to feel like it like there's a
man protector we have an actor even
after that guy tackled him he's still
yelling the guys the other guys left he
calm down it's hard that's how you know
yeah he's just a dick yeah yeah for
everybody that feels sympathy for this
guy who doesn't feel sympathy for the
insell [ __ ] runner online that's the
to this guy yes right those insult
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] blockers want to
kill girls could that because their
personality sucks so bad all of his
problems are his women yeah he's yelling
at all the women at bagel store they
didn't even say anything to him right
he's short you know did you notice that
he's not as tall as the other people in
the store I did that's a shame huh yep
but do you see the women that he's
yelling at behind the counter he can't
see over the counter and he knows her
back hear them perfume
who's he with that's guiding him out all
got pushed him it was just a guy thank
you I get the [ __ ] the guys walking out
and the guy walks and puts his hands on
his shoulder and pushes him out I'll
take care of it is [ __ ] he doing he said
all the women are too [ __ ] up
he's on a hairline trigger he is but
just the way the I ended like again a
guy walking just kind of shaft shoving
him out the door what the [ __ ] yeah that
guy said Oh what does we're not doing
anything you're not even the guy that
tackled him you're not you're not the
big man here he's leaving anyway yeah
hey get rid of him
don't worry ladies I got the situation
under control
oh good I'm so glad we had you here camo
shorts yeah you know I'm so glad you
were here to take care of things but a
lot of guys won't confront him because
they don't want to get beat up I look
like he must have a fight
he doesn't though no no no he's getting
tackled
yet he went down like a dummy in NFL
practice really dealt like a dummy at
the combine and the guy I guess I guess
the guy got pulled off I want to see how
the guy got off him yeah cuz I would
have thought he was gonna stay on him
until the cops came or something just
pull his head if she's a little shirt
over his head and like Majan the hell
degrading that beat and tickle him him a
wedgie
yeah him a wedgie drag him into the
bathroom and shove his face in the
forgive him for whatever the flushy or
whatever they're called shove his face
in the toilet swirly swirly that's what
it is give him a you think he's ever had
a swirly you think it's cool the bully's
got him with a swirly probably all them
are the ankles yeah yeah shake out his
lunch money a plunger
yeah well put that plunger I bet he was
the same way in high school I'll bet he
was this short little guy that we
thought he could fight everybody and got
beaten up all the time but then you get
to like you know your forties and you're
just not getting laid you start to lose
it apparently yeah I wouldn't know I've
gotten laid at least twice and that's
confirmed I would love to know who this
guy is
I'm just curious about his life you know
why if I was in this situation I would
not intervene or tackle or do anything I
would want it to go on as long as
possible would you enjoy it I would love
it I would go to the back of the line in
the bagel store because I wouldn't want
my experience to be shortened I would
want to stay I would be
paradise for me in that store I would
adore it if I was sitting there my wife
would probably go like Oh Sam we got to
do something I go just take the kids
home I'm gonna I'm gonna camp out here
for a while and watch this I want to see
what's going on but I'll be honest
goddamn it that doesn't make me want a
bagel [ __ ] it does bagels are great
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]